okay so let's begin the second talk on
De reduction and lower
B I want to thank the organizers for
organizing this wonderful program here
uh and I want to present a survey of
some recent
results about depth reduction and lower
bounds uh for arithmetic circuits so
this stock will be self-contained and
just in case I
uh I have some terminology which I don't
introduce please stop me and
ask uh in the last Workshop clim already
talked about depth reduction so I
thought I will give an overview of the
depth reduction results but focus more
on Lower bonds and a specific lower
bound so I'll try to give you the full
proof of that lower
bound so let's begin so I will tell you
what the lower bound specific lower
bound result is that I will talk about
today I then give the background and
motivation this will be the survey part
of the talk then I will try to give you
a full proof of this lower
bound and uh and that's it so so here's
the
statement that I want to talk about
today
so I'll present to you an explicit
family of polinomial of degree D on DQ
variables such that if you write it as a
sum of product of homogeneous
polinomial the size of the
expression of this expression of as a
sum of product of
polinomial must be at least 2 to the
root D log D so roughly exponential in
square root D and you'll see in a moment
why we worry about the log factors also
so Omega is a
constant uh yes there there will be a
constant hidden here and this constant
will be
about5 and so you're
saying the total number of monomials in
in the total number of
QJ so uh so so I just by the size of
this expression on the right hand side
it's it's a natural way of how you would
uh count the size of such an expression
you uh you just look at uh take all the
qi's look at how many monomials they
have and add this up this is the size of
my expression and is this for any choice
of basis or no it will be it will be for
the Natural Choice of
basis uh yeah so you will see a basis
independent theorem later but this will
will fix a basis and yeah I don't know
how to get rid of this basis here and Qi
some fixed set of homogeneous polom no
no arbitrary qig you so uh so for
example this is almost true uh this per
this polom FD could be the
permanent I want
to almost philosophically show you that
uh if you write the permanent as a sum
of product of SP pols then you'll have
to use at least 2 to the root D
monomials see I'm bit confused about Qi
is just a homogeneous polomia it's just
a homogeneous Pol so I could just take
Qi to be FD because FD is supposed to be
homogeneous but uh so FD will be dense
uh so you have a polinomial of degree D
Cube on D variables D Cube variables and
degree D so it will have two to the if
you take the naive expression FD will
have more than that number of
monomials is what he's saying I see so
FD has some large number of monomials
and he says you cannot rewrite it in
this
way and uh yeah have a lot more
monomials than the naive expr than that
right
yes uh and yeah but this reminds me of a
point which I think I should clarify
that you can have products of sparse
pooms being very dense so for example if
you look at 1 + X1 + so on just the
linear form which adds up all the
variables and raise it to the DS
power this is a polinomial of degree D
in N variables which has maximum
possible sparity it has all possible
monomials that's why because you choose
bad
basis yeah
so so at least what this suggest is that
a knife monomial counting won't
work so this will be over real numbers
and complex numbers any field of
characteristic zero this is the our
computer science meaning of Express no
but that monom if you change the bis can
be done
easily this particular monomial yes so
so so so is this result dependent upon
your choice of of variables yes it is
and but you will see
a basis independent result for that also
no no certainly not for
this
sorry yes in fact 01 they are all
01 so uh yeah you'll you you'll see in a
moment I'll make uh things even more
clearer so first of all let me say that
one more yeah and for deter the same
bound holds with what to the Omega s
root d right root D
yes and the same for
permanent for the permanent uh uh yes so
the best lower bounds that we know are 2
to the root D for determinant and
permanent there's a gap
uh slight Gap in the
lower there a Sim lower yes yeah I'm
coming to that so so first of all I want
to mention that if you take a generic
polinomial of degree D on dcbe variables
and want to write it like this any such
expression will have size exponential in
D log D this is a standard counting
argument our lower bound is roughly 2 to
the root D for a generic polom is 2 to
the D so there's a lot of room for
improvement here that's what I want to
point out
on the other
hand if you make any Improvement to this
lower bound if you improve this to root
D log Square D let's say it will imply
that VP is not equal to vnp and I'll
will tell you
why uh and uh okay so
uh after our work mininal Kumar and
shubangi saraf they improved it in
uh this result here it's almost the same
result this polom FD is just the
iterated matrix multiplication
polinomial and it's sufficiently
computable so I'll will tell you what
the iterated matrix multiplication
polinomial is and this is both bad news
and good news uh so let me explain
this the it shows in in some sense it
gives evidence that
uh the particular techniques that we
used in this
proof are also give lower bounds for
efficiently computable polinomial so
maybe it might not work for resolving VP
versus VMP because it it's working also
for efficiently computable
polinomial on the other hand it's it
does not mathematically prove that you
cannot do it because the constant that
you get here is is much worse than what
we know for polinomial in V vnp so our
constant in the previous thing is like
maybe 0.5 this constant is maybe
01 but this is either the 10th variables
also so
yes but this is good news because it
helps us understand another basic
question in algebraic complexity and and
I'll will tell you what that
is so uh so yeah any questions about the
statement of the
result so f is what now it's Matrix what
is FB now yeah so you
take D matrices of size d to the 10 each
so D the 10 by D to the 10 matrices D of
them multiply them and take the trace of
the product so you get a polinomial and
that's the trace of that product yes FD
is the trace of this product and again
you are going to write it in terms of uh
the entri of the Matrix
yes
I linear polom no no they are arbitrary
homogeneous polins
No No linearity in fact here there's no
restriction on the degree at
all are products like the the product
are also homogeneous is it like entirely
homogeneous or not you only need the
qis so yeah that's a good question so we
only need the Qs to be homogeneous
because once you have a product of
homogeneous
polinomial uh it's also again a
homogeneous pols and any homogeneous
smand here which is of degree mod than D
you can just throw it away because it is
never going to contribute anything to a
degree D homogeneous polom so if you
allow nonhomogeneous the proof won't
work is it no it doesn't work because
there could be lots of canellation yes
and you'll see
the yes and you'll see we now know
something that there's a fundamental
reason there okay so so let me just very
quickly uh recall what arithmetic
circuits are uh you you have seen them
already so we have have addition and
multiplication Gates and you build up a
circuit in the natural way uh by a
sequence of these operations I just want
to mention here that our addition Gates
we will allow arbitrary constants on the
edges so so our addition gate is in fact
Computing a linear combination of the
inputs an arbitrary linear combination
of the
inputs and now the size of a circuit is
just the number of edges in this
graph and we care about the depth of the
circuit this is the length of a longest
path in the circuit and we care about
the depth because in some sense low
depth circuits correspond to computation
which is highly parallel so to see this
you can imagine if you given a circuit
uh like this and if you plug in specific
values for the
xise the depth tells you after how much
time will you get uh the result at the
output
so uh low depth is high parallelism in
this
computation so so these are the things
that we care
about and uh in this talk we will always
work over uh the complex
numbers and our gates will always have
unbounded Fanon unless I tell you
otherwise what is fan oh multip things
five
things so the question was what is Fanon
it is uh you can multiply arbitrary
number of uh objects at one time or add
an arbitrary number of objects at one
time okay so so now these are sort of
the two basic questions that we care
about uh in complexity in general and in
also in arithmetic complexity we want to
understand what can be computed
efficiently and what can be computed
efficiently in parallel so
let's we have more specific
things more specific versions of these
questions so uh so so for the first
problem one uh specific aim is to
understand whether explicit polinomial
can be efficiently computed so if you
don't like explicit here just think of
it whether the permanent has small
arithmetic circuits or not it's
equivalent to that does the permanent
have polinomial sized arithmetic
circuits or
not and the SEC and this another basic
question is can computation be
efficiently
paralyzed
uh is it true that whatever piece of
computation can be done by small
circuits can also be done by small
shallow
circuits
is it possible to explain that in more
yes so I will just uh take an example
now to explain this so uh so let's look
at this example of iterated matrix
multiplication so it is this polinomial
and this is the same polinomial which
occurred in the Kumar saraf
result you want to essentially you just
want to multiply D matrices d n byn
matrices and just to make since the
product of D matrices is a matrix so it
has lots of polins we just take the
trace of the output to make it into a
single
polom so so just think of it as
multiplying D matrices and there's a
natural way to do it you can do it one
by one multiply X1 with X2 and so on and
you get a circuit of size uh D * n n
Cube or n the Omega if you
want but now you can ask whether this
can be computed in parallel and in this
case it's easy to see that you can
exploit the associativity of matrix
multiplication to do to do this in
parallel so for
example uh you first take X1 and X2
multiply them but in
parallel multiply X1 and x x x 3 and X4
and so on XD minus one and XD and by
this here this operation star here I
mean you plug in your favorite matrix
multiplication
algorithm so this will actually be a sum
of product of sums if you use the fast
matrix multiplication if you use the KN
matrix multiplication you'll replace
this star by uh a sum of
products but yeah this just plug in your
favorite matrix multiplication algorithm
Here and Now notice that I have reduced
my problem of multiplying D matrices
into a problem of multiplying d by two
matrices and so just
recurse and doing
this doing this recursively and taking
the trace at the
end you get a
circuit uh which is of polinomial size
but the depth is log D logarithmic in
the
degree right so now we can ask
uh well can one do better can one reduce
the depth also
and the one other thing one can ask is
whether one can do it for arbitrary
circuits and this is a wonderful result
by vant vant SK covid and
recov uh very beautiful it says that
take any Circuit of sizes any any
arbitary Circuit of size s you can have
another equivalent Circuit of slightly
larger size say s
square and the depth is log D which
computes the same
polom Unbound I'm allowing unbounded
Fanon yeah so what uh clim point was is
uh in valiant's original statement it
was log D log s but there he was
allowing bounded fan Gates of fan and 2
but here I'm allowing unbounded fanin so
you can always expand a gate with fanin
s into a sequence of G Gates of uh depth
log but but it is cubic the size is Cub
sorry I for yeah it's either it's
certainly less than cubic I forgot
whether it's quadratic or cubic I think
for mathematicians probably mention that
the field size has to be large enough
all that no no this in this this is for
arbitrary field in fact this is true
even for Boolean circuits
but so okay I mean you don't think of it
as a circuit you think of it as a pol
whatever yeah so you can Define the
notion of a formal degree of a circuit
and what this D will be the formal
degree of the circuit yeah I mean you're
thinking of it as algebraic closure of
F2 not not really Boolean ciruit that's
what uh yeah
so so so we know this this is I mean
wonderful we we can reduce the depth to
log D but in recent years people started
asking more refined versions of this
question suppose if I want to do it even
smaller let's say constant depth Delta
or maybe log log depths and you can ask
in general if I want to take a circuit
of
sizes and reduce the depth to
Delta how much larger must this new
circuit be what's the best you can do
with a circuit of size of depth Delta
can you say size s and degree D this
degree refers to the degree of the polom
computed by the circuit yes uh
uh it refers to the degree of the
polinomial computed by the circuit
there's one very nice LMA in this proof
that for arithmetic circuits we can
essentially assume without loss of
generality that the degree of the
circuit is the same as the degree of the
output
polinomial so specifically you can take
a an arbitrary circuit which might
compute very high degree polinomial in
between but you can convert it into
another circuit which is in fact
homogeneous and the size just blows up
to S * D ² which computes the same polom
so so the circuit is homogeneous yeah in
fact this circuit is
homogeneous as if you're Computing a
homogeneous polom otherwise if if it's a
general polom you just add up its
homogeneous components at the end so the
degree of the circuit is the maximum of
the degrees of all the intermediate pols
no degree yeah so let me just quickly do
that so essentially you start with the
inputs this degree is
zero and any input with a labeled with a
variable the degree is one and now you
inductively define the degree like this
whenever you multiply two things you add
up the degree and whenever you add two
things you take the Max of the degree of
the
children and that gives you yeah notion
for degree of a
circuit okay U yeah and if you do the
same thing for Boolean circuits the same
notion of formal degree for Boolean
circuits Vance theorem is true even for
Boolean
circuits so okay
so so now let's see again another
example where let's say we want to do it
in depth
four so suppose we want to now do
iterated matrix
multiplication by a a depth four
circuit so we are allowed sums of
products of sums of products so but in
this case it will again be very
natural you divide your D matrices into
uh blocks of equal
size then multiply all the blocks
multiply all the matrices within a
single block together in the first two
levels of the circuit and then multiply
the outputs of those blocks again in the
next two levels of the circuit and the
block size it turns out the optimal
block size is square root
D and uh so if you look at the size of
this knce circuit for the iterated
matrix multiplication the size is n to
the square root d
this n the square root D comes from uh
the fact that when you want to multiply
square root D matrices and you're doing
it in the trivial way as a sum of
products the the it has so many
monomials in
it so each star is depth two each star
is again a depth two yes
uh so we have seen that matrix
multiplication you can do much better uh
one can ask can you one do iterated
matrix multiplication much better than
this is multiplication yeah this is so
the question is can one do bet can one
beat n to the square root
d uh okay and but more generally for
matrix multiplication if you are allowed
circuits of depth Delta you can do it in
this much size n to the D to the 1 over
Delta sorry it should be 2 over
Delta in the obvious in the obvious way
yes and
uh again what is it this says s root D
that says what this is D to the 2/ delta
this two should be in the numerator
here so U and it's OB obvious way of
doing
it so so some of these recent depth
reduction results is asked about this
more refined version of vant
question uh and and we have some results
that for arbitrary circuits
you start out with an arbitrary Circuit
of size
s you can simulate
it with a Delta depth Circuit of size s
to the D to the 2/ Delta so in some
sense this is saying that there's
nothing special about iterated matrix
multiplication you can do it for any
piece of arithmetic computation this
depth
reduction but you finally reduce it to
multi matrix multiplication in some
sense yeah you can do that you lose some
log factors here and to get rid of those
log factors uh tavasi went back to vant
original proof and controlled the
degrees much more
carefully and now one can ask is this
optimal is this the best we can do for
depth reduction
uh so okay maybe it's a good time to
take a guess
um
guess uh what do you think is it
optimal well I have two answers for you
yes and
no uh
so
so so yeah so there's a lower Bond so
okay let me explain this lower bound so
in general we don't know this is still
open uh but so uh suppose so I want to
just uh explain this lower Bond so in
this lower Bond uh we look at specific
kinds of circuits so it's motivated by
by the kind of circuits that we know get
in the
existing depth reduction results so
let's look at the circuit for
itated matrix multiplication so notice
it has this property that it's a
homogeneous circuit at every node you're
Computing a homogeneous
polinomial
and moreover you have these
layers in the circuit and all the
polinomial at the same layer have the
same
degree
so first you will uh maybe multiply some
of these monomials together then add
them up and so on so it turns out that
in in these depth reductions
also uh this more General depth
reductions also the circuits that you
get have this property that these are
homogeneous
circuits they are layered and at each
layer the degrees of the polinomial are
well not exactly the same but almost the
same approximately the same
so so if you have these kind of circuits
I call them regular
circuits this upper bound that you get
is essentially
optimal uh and
uh for depth four you can even uh remove
the Restriction of regularity uh just
assume that the circuit is homogeneous
and for that that also it's
optimal from the theorem that I told you
in the beginning so so this is uh the
significance of that of that result
that you repeat the
definition yeah so
this uh the circuit is
homogeneous and at each layer in the
Circuit look at the pols computed at
that layer they all have the same
degree so that's what I will call a
regular circuit
with so just to make sure what's WR here
in the bottom left is exactly the
few yes and what is the first one if
shallow what is shallow uh like if the
if the resulting Delta depth circuit is
regular
so what is shallow Del Delta yes
the
so in particular for homogeneous depth
circuits uh homogeneous depth four
circuits this is
optimal uh
and and that might have been the end of
the story except that we know uh that
even for homogeneous depth 4 we can do
much better even for depth four without
the homogeneity restriction we can do
much better so for example for itated
matrix multiplication you have a circuit
of size n to the cube root of D if you
allow
non-homogeneity and in fact this
construction that we know it's highly
nonhomogeneous it at intermediate levels
of this circuit it computes pols which
are have exponentially large
degree and then somehow all the degree
High degree monomials cancel out leaving
you with the low degree output that you
want going back to this lower left
didn't the theem has some logarithm in
the
exponent
is
s so yeah so in the earlier statements I
had sort of taken this s into the
exponent with writing it as
logs uh yeah so uh so this is the
overview uh in the rest of this talk
I'll focus on this lower bound so any
questions about yeah so
so so hom you can homogenize a circuit
but I guess the depth goes up yes yes
or the other thing you could do is
instead of computing the polinomial you
want you compute the padded version of
the polinomial and then you and then you
can homogenize as
well if you're willing to compute a
paded polom mean you know what you're
the one who initiated padded polinomial
so anyone in this room should know what
that means it should be you if you're
willing to compute the paded version of
your Pol
then you can use homogeneous circuits
just homogenize
everywhere so I don't know have
homogeneous polom you just multiply by
power of linear form that's correct and
then just throw that everywhere inside
your circuit to make it homogeneous and
then there may be a power
left the problem this lower doesn't work
for okay so this is uh the the the lower
Bond I'll focus on today I'll try to
give you a proof of
it
very so so let me remind you what the
lower bond is we we want to write a
polinomial as a sum of product of pooms
of homogeneous pols and I want to prove
a lower bound of roughly 2 to the square
root
D so so here's here will be our proof
strategy uh we'll try to ident Identify
some nice geometric property of shallow
circuits of small shallow
circuits will then
Express this geometric property in terms
of the rank of some very big
Matrix and then for our explicit
polinomial on the left hand side we'll
show that this rank is
large so uh to make this somewhat more
precise let me give you a sense of of
these
numbers so this Matrix this big Matrix
that we have will be of size 2 to the DQ
by 2 the D so just to put this in
perspective our polinomial is of degree
D so it has
roughly uh d d to the D
coefficient
so so so roughly 2 to the D coefficients
but this Matrix is going to be much
larger
much larger than even the coefficient
representation of the PO is unbounded
right yeah this the size of this Matrix
is unrelated to the
Fanon no I I thought before that you
said something about monom to the D
monomial or something like so yeah I
just wanted to compare the size of this
Matrix with the size of F I mean how
many coefficients does f have our our
polinomial is a polinomial of degree D
so it has D to the
D
coefficients so just to put these
numbers in perspective and uh it it will
turn out that for our
polinomial this rank will be basically
the size of the Matrix we'll lose only a
polinomial factor po factor in the rank
so I'll show you but uh this rank will
be essentially the size of the
Matrix uh okay
and now I want to point out how small
this relatively small is because I want
to highlight the fact that this argument
is somewhat
delicate so this Matrix the rank will uh
the small rank will be roughly almost du
to the D Cube so you don't
see any uh difference in the ranks here
and
here uh but notice that the constants in
in front of the DQ bar exactly the same
so we look at the next coefficient and
that next coefficient will also be
exactly the same roughly d s log squ
D so we'll look at the next one and this
coefficient here will be slightly larger
than this coefficient here and that will
that is essentially the reason we get a
two to the root de of lower
B
so it's uh so so what is important here
is not the sizes of these matrices but
the ratios of the ranks of these
matrices that's the number that we care
about not not the absolute numbers this
ratio is the only thing that we care
about okay so let me uh tell you yeah
perspec this one of the flattenings that
we saw um doing the other no this is
going to be a different kind of
flattening it's flat it is a flattening
but it's a different kind than
you come tomorrow know what sure so so
we we want to start with geometry so we
want to identify some nice geometric
property of shallow
circuits so
uh let's just first
rewrite the definition of a Sal circuit
in our case it was a circuit is shallow
if it is a sum of product of low degree
polinomial okay sorry one uh thing I
should have mentioned
uh I will assume here for now assume
that our homogeneous polinomial have
degrees have small degrees say deg
square root d
so this low here will be square root D
and for now assume that this Qs have deg
S
root so this is just another way of
saying that our polinomial can be
written as a sum of D where the
variety uh corresponding to each TI this
is a hypers Surface but it's a union of
low degree hypersurfaces
and uh ideally I should have been able
to convert this statement into the
statement about the rank of a matrix but
I don't know how to do that and uh this
that is one of the reasons uh I'm here
I'm hoping to find out how to do that
but uh but uh I'll use a relaxation of
it so
in particular it
means that each of these hypers surfaces
which is actually a union of low degree
hypersurfaces it has lots of
singularities so so let me just explain
this so suppose you have a product of
two homogeneous
pols so take any common zero of those
two pols so by V q1 Q2 I will just mean
the common Zer of two pols
so any point which is a common zero of
two
pols that is a
singularity for the product so for
example if you look at any partial
derivative of the
product then and evaluate the partial
derivative at a common z a then it
vanishes right because q1 and Q2 vanish
at
and
so so uh another way to say it
geometrically would be that the variety
of the partial derivatives of T contains
the variety of q1 Q2 and now notice that
this variety has very large Dimension
because it's common zeros of only two
pols so so this variety also on the left
has large
Dimension and now we can generalize this
uh if you can take higher order
derivative you can take K order
derivative and the variety of the K
order derivatives of T has Dimension at
least n minus
t of when you have a product of t
pooms
and
now so uh so so let me just restate our
geometric observation that if you have a
shallow
circuit then you can write it as a sum
of polinomial such
that the uh each of those
summands they have lots of high order
singularities so so this is the
geometric property that we'll try to
exploit so now how to express this in
terms of the rank of a
matrix so so we'll use a wellknown
theorem by
hbert so it's about the dimension uh
dimensionality of a variety if you have
it says that if you have a variety given
by an explicit set of pols you can write
down the linear map so that the rank of
the linear map will tell you about the
dimension of the variety so specifically
you do the
following so suppose you take any
variety defined by polom P1 P2 PS in our
case the the P here will be the
derivatives of
T so we are interested in this variety
instead uh now let's look at this linear
map
so it takes as input a bunch of s
polinomial these AIS are pols and by
this I mean the set of pols of degree at
most
L it takes as input a set of L pooms and
it outputs the summation
aipi so you can verify that this is a
linear map so if you think think of
these AIS as vectors this is a linear
map
and what Hilbert told us is
that uh the dimension of a variety the
information about the dimension of the
variety is hidden in the rank of this
linear map in particular if the
dimension is large then the rank of this
map is
small and uh in we'll have to quantify
this uh in our
case so uh so
here's the upper bound that we have that
if we have a polinomial which is a sum
of s products of
polinomial where each of the qi's have
degree T this T will become root D
eventually so what is it what was the
statement again so the quality uh what
say
exactly uh yeah actually the so the
exact thing was look at the image of
this linear map and look at the co
Dimension think of that as a function of
L it that will turn out to be a
polinomial in L function yes
yes yeah
so so
we upper bound
u in our specific case we can for a sum
of product of low degree polinomial we
can upper bound the rank by this
much and this is a relatively easy
calculation that you don't need that
Astic thing as he was
do for this kinds
of so what he's referring to here is
that this small and large was sort of in
the astics and that is a more General
reason but it holds in Astic whereas
here the main thing is that for this
specific thing you can remove
the you have to choose large enough but
not too
large yeah but there it can be
like I mean that's the
main okay uh okay so uh we started 5
minutes late can we take okay nothing I
mean you don't go too much
Beyond try to finish in five minutes
this is an ad this L is an adoptation
of no no
no yeah it's a more direct computation
this is an inequality and function sorry
because there are ALB geomet lots of
reses on no he has very specific
information
this
is uh okay so uh basically this gives us
a way of expressing this geometric
property that we started with in terms
of rank of the
Matrix uh and now we have to show that
for our specific polinomial FD the rank
is
large
so oh I don't
know anyway okay so this uh I
can oh the proof completes
because uh okay so so let me tell you
this is uh it's
so the thing here is we
have we have a very large matrix it's
exponentially large and I want to prove
to you that the rank of this Matrix is
large how do I do that one way to do
this might have been the following
suppose if I could find this large
submatrix inside it which was upper
triangular say
uh and Zer here and anything here so
suppose if I could find a large
combinatorial submatrix here which was
upper triangular then the size of this
submatrix would be a lower bound on the
rank and in the and this is I I find
this to be an ex really amazing fact
about the
determinant that if you start with the
determinant
this the rank of this Matrix is in fact
the size of the smallest upper
triangular Matrix inside
it and it it basically follows from one
very
sorry yeah sorry largest sub uh upper
triangular submatrix inside it and uh
it's follows from a fact about which
holds only for the determinant or for
very few
determinant is one of them this is
St yeah it's by burn stom fils that the
minor of the determinant form a groer
basis for the ideal that they generate
so because of that we know this and so
we could do this computation for the
determinant and we got a lower Bond of 2
to the root
D but we wanted to do bit better so what
you use that that fact that it is a
Gris actually it was not really needed
because we just needed a lower Bond but
it kind of helped us to uh because uh we
knew that we at least for the
determinant by just looking at large
triangular submatrices in principle we
could compute the rank for General M
matrices this this is hopeless right I
mean uh for a general Matrix you might
not find any upper triangular submatrix
in it so I'm little confused about what
is the connection between the Matrix and
the polom like
determinant so this is
the yeah
this
IDE so what is Matrix corresponding to
the so it's this Matrix you take the
derivatives of the determinant which are
minors and then look at the ideal of
those
miners I'm going to do it again tomorrow
morning uh comp I haven't heard of this
term but you look at the ideal generated
by the
miners and uh take a slice of that ideal
and look at its
Dimension that's the Matrix correspond
actually in albra commun is they have
exponential size matri and they show
that the rank is almost this kind of
them
occur find such
minor
yes told you that it's not
L yes it should have been such yes
exactly
for you only have this method you don't
know if like for the yes for the
permanent we don't know it's optimal and
probably it is not probably the rank is
larger than
the so okay so I want to tell you one
very nice result by Alon though so
there's another very nice method for
find to
certify rank of large matrices it's the
following so think of The Columns of
your Matrix suppose The Columns are A1
through
AC and suppose for a moment that the
columns were pairwise
orthogonal then then the rank of this
Matrix would be the number of non-zero
columns but now suppose The Columns are
not exactly orthogonal but almost
orthogonal and in that case Alon gives
us a way of lower bounding the ranks of
such matrices and
essentially uh you look at
M look at B which is M transpose
M
and the rank of M will be lower
bounded by Trace of
b square by Trace of b
s uh so this
is in hindsight it's a simple inequality
but amazingly
powerful so in fact uh what is that what
is that so uh take
theity two lines but it's as you said
it's very simple and very powerful the
is just one
application so yeah so we use this uh to
prove that our Matrix indeed has large
rank so comp
mat uh yes essentially true yes you I
mean do the natural thing do the
conjugate
transpose so and this was also used this
is a general fact completely
generally yeah yeah I think it's
extremely powerful and very helpful
here
because so so that said
uh so okay uh but one last remark I
cheated you a bit I st stated the
theorem with qi's being arbitrary
homogeneous polinomial and then later on
I assumed the Qs to have low degree de
square root d uh so so we need
to uh prove this and The Germ of this
idea was given to me by AI Vasan and in
independently observed by my co-authors
that essentially you do a random
restriction but we couldn't get the
random restriction to work but later it
turns out that if you view a random
restriction as going modul and ideal
then you can choose your ideal suitably
and and then just redo the entire proof
and it happens to work so that's how you
remove this de assumption
yes so so we yeah what we are doing here
is removing the degree assumption and
replacing it by the sparsity of the
qag so so that's it any
questions
question any in reason why we can
generalize to the five ciruit
no none that I know of in fact uh uh in
some sense I'm hoping that it might
generalize to let's say homogeneous
formulas or non-homogeneous even
nonhomogeneous
formulas uh but certainly I mean not not
this
particular measure maybe maybe we'll
have to think about how to adapt it yeah
I don't but it's not clear that that
five is a the right question question D
four is the right question just improve
and to the root D to slightly bigger and
you are done and big is there okay it's
different like who you ask like if you
want to talk with algebraic geometrist
you will not able to hear about dep four
at all why not I mean this is all albic
geometry the
tools algebra with intuition from
algebraic geometry explain the intu you
some some
symmetry are much more symmetric than
well just the sigma lamb Sigma
lamb in fact if you can improve it uh
for any Pol for any Express poal if you
can improve over any field if you can
improve this it will in particular imply
that permanent is cannot be written as a
small determinant over that
field
then I didn't say
anything
yeah thank
you
now
I